-Our first guest
is a multi-platinum
Grammy-winning music superstar.
You can see her as a coach
on "The Voice"
every Monday and Tuesday
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.
Please welcome Ariana Grande!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Ha ha ha! Ahh!
Mwah! Mwah! I love you.
-I love you so much.
I miss you. I miss New York.
I miss your face,
even though I just saw you.
-Yeah. We just saw each other.
You did me a favor.
You were on my show,
"That's My Jam,"
which is going to air
after "The Voice."
Yeah, it's really fun.
It's, like, little
music mini games.
-It is very fun. I felt like
I was on another planet.
-[ Laughs ]
You'll see it.
But, it's -- Yeah,
you were fantastic in it.
But 'cause you also just --
'Cause you know how to act, too.
You'll see it. It's funny.
But speaking of acting,
you're in a new movie
coming out next month
called "Don't Look Up."
-Yes.
-This is directed by Adam McKay.
I love Adam McKay.
It is a huge cast.
Meryl Streep, Jennifer Lawrence,
Leonardo DiCaprio,
Tyler Perry, Timothée Chalamet,
Ariana Grande.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right there.
How do you --
-Oh. There it is.
-There it is, right there.
How do you --
How did you get the part?
Did you talk to McKay or did...?
-So this was --
it was so exciting because
I -- I love Adam McKay.
I'm such a fan of his work.
I'm such a comedy fan.
And I adore him.
And he reached out,
and he said, you know,
"I have this role for you
in my new movie."
And I was like,
"Oh, my God. Well, hold on
because I have to audition.
I need to earn this.
I need to put myself on tape.
When can I come in for it?"
And he was like, "No, no, no.
It's not -- It's a tiny thing.
It's a tiny, quick thing."
I was like, "Okay, okay.
Let me read it.
I want to make sure
I can do this."
And, so, I just -- I read it.
I loved it. It's brilliant.
I have this tiny but such
a fun and incredible part.
I feel so excited that
I got to be a part of this.
It was so cool.
-Who do you play?
-I play Riley Bina,
who is this aloof
and somewhat unaware pop star
whose relationship
with DJ Cello,
played by
the amazing Kid Cudi --
The news about
their relationship fluctuating
sort of eclipses the news
of the Earth coming to an end,
which is great.
-Fantastic. "Don't Look Up"
is in select theaters
December 10th
and on Netflix December 24th.
Congrats on that.
Are we going to see more acting
of Ariana in the future?
-I would love that.
I hope so, yeah.
-I was just talking
to a friend of mine
who said that he saw you
on Broadway in like --
Was it "13"? Is that the name
of a show that you were in?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, oh, my God!
Who is this friend?
Thanks for coming.
-No, he said,
even watching you --
You were probably 13
when you were doing it.
He goes, you could tell
that you were going to be
a superstar.
They were like,
"That kid's got it."
-Oh, my God! What?
Thank you. That's so nice.
-Yeah.
-I feel like you made this up.
Thank you, though.
-Actually, I really didn't.
I swear. Yeah.
I didn't see it.
My friend saw it. Yeah.
-Oh, Okay.
-But I will say -- I don't
even know what we can say,
but we have a special
little fun thing
for everyone that's a secret
that's going to come out soon.
-Oh, my God, yes. I'm so excited
about this secret.
Is it your skin-care routine?
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's a different thing,
my skin-care routine.
But --
-Oh.
Would you like to walk them
through that or no?
-No, I don't, because that was
the most embarrassing
thing ever.
-It was the best moment
of my life.
It was so much fun. Sorry.
Go ahead. We don't have to
tell them. It's fine.
-Okay. Yeah, okay.
I didn't want to talk about it.
But we can show two
little things of this secret,
and it's --
It just wants to bring
a little joy to people
and a smile to people
during the holidays.
But this is one picture
that you took on set, a selfie.
You can see kind of
where we're kind of going.
We never quite used --
Do you still have your bag?
-I sure do.
-I love you, bud,
I have mine, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to do that
right after this interv--
Oh, come on. I love you.
-These were --
These were full of wine on set.
I wanted to point that out.
-They were.
They're not --
Mine's not full anymore.
-Mine either.
-[ Laughs ]
But we can --
Honestly, we can show
a little bit of video footage
from what we did.
Again, we can't say what it is,
but maybe you can figure it out
if you just watch this.
-It's top-secret,
but check it out.
-Yeah.
Okay, there you go.
-That might give it away.
-That's all I can say.
That's it.
That's all we can do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They definitely --
I think that was too much.
They're definitely
going to know how.
-Yeah. Now they're gonna know.
Everyone knows what it is.
But anyway,
you'll see really soon,
and it's going to make you smile
for the holidays.
But I want to ask you
this question.
Because I heard this story
that -- Because I --
Honestly, you are one
of the hardest workers I know.
And you have a great...
-Oh, thank you.
--...work ethic.
-You, as well.
-No, I mean, just --
I mean, we did that thing
after we did the other thing
and "The Voice."
I'm like --
-And then you got on a plane
to New York that night.
It was crazy.
-No, but this is --
I'm talking about you now.
This is you.
-Oh.
-I heard a story that you
once called Nickelodeon.
You were 4 years old
and called Nickelodeon and said,
"I want to be on Nickelodeon."
-Yes. I have this weird
manifesting gift, I think.
When I was 4 years old,
I called -- I did 411,
and they said, "Location,"
or whatever.
And I was like,
"Orlando, Florida."
And they were like,
"Who are you calling?"
And I was like,
"Universal Studios."
And I got through somehow.
Like, by some miracle,
I got through.
And they were like, "Hey.
Universal Studios, Orlando."
And I said, "Hi. I would
like to audition to be on
'All That' or 'The Amanda Show.'
Your pick. You tell me."
-"It's totally up to you guys."
-"It's up to you,
but I would love to be
on either/or. Your pick."
And they were like,
"How old are you?"
And I was like,
"Don't worry about it."
And they were like,
"Are your parents around?"
And I was like, "No."
-No.
-And then I think
she hung up and...
-But you got your big break
not too long after that.
I don't know
if you remember this.
It's your first singing gig.
You were 8 years old.
You sang the national anthem at
a Florida Panthers hockey game.
-Oh, my gosh.
Are we going here?
Yes, that was my first gig.
My first big gig.
-I want to thank your mom
for getting us this footage.
And best to everyone. Best
to Nonna. Best to Frankie.
But I want to show this.
-Thank you.
-Here's Ariana Grande,
8 years old,
singing the national anthem.
Look at this.
-♪ O say,
does that star-spangled ♪
♪ Banner yet wave ♪
♪ O'er the land
of the fr-e-e-e-ee ♪
♪ And the home ♪
♪ Of the brave ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is a star right there!
That little dimple is so cute.
More -- I want to talk about
"The Voice" when we come back.
More with Ariana Grande
after the break.